Wow jaysus guys let me start my friggin
Vidya oh my face
step up I love spitting Jesus guys I
tried waking up oh my god you can't
sleep in walk on you eat you it's like
every custom story out there now that's
me in it
alright I have a line item all right
sivanna I mean I am Savannah its Christ
I did not expect the water [ __ ]
monster 19 3 1 2 carpeting Oh Ron minute
don't look back what about you - hi
disappeared sweet
I don't like this very much
it's water yeah
all right he can't walk here stupid
water
oh we're in trouble well oh it's cold
out now it's gone
let's go let's go let's go bow back yep
oh my [ __ ] penis oh oh I guess listen
I don't ever [ __ ] look back oh my god
that's Hollywood
Oh God dang it now okay fine at least we
have time to get why can I walk here I
shouldn't be able to walk I shouldn't be
able to splash Jesus penis that's scared
I think my penis just flew off that's
not good the flames he should realize I
am recording ah there you are
what the hell I am disappointed at you
severely y'all supposed to run but no
you have to go and die every time how
many hours are you played this game per
day tell me how can he still be so bad
at it I don't understand
but I'm French that's okay Mexican what
are you dissing your set enough cos not
French
we will eyes and think of all stuff
anyway this is continued good is my
name's Adam no it's [ __ ] you talking
about alright
don't don't don't talk down on me I
hey hey what's going on we escaped
Nightmare Moon I sure [ __ ] hope so I
don't know how much he left there is of
this custom story I mean they could
could end here for as much as I know all
right where does it Stefan ah back there
in a corridor to that's oh oh this is
where the [ __ ] teleporting [ __ ]
barrels teleporting naked guy came in
the last episode uh-huh we can't go
there I'm fine
barrels barrels nice [ __ ] ape
all right it's cool it's cool it's cool
it's cool don't try to make love right
in front of me [ __ ] bow let's go no
it's gone I don't like this
I'm gonna kill me I know it for shizzle
what's inside this one hey my friends
old pizza helpful that's all alright
let's follow the period that's what my
mom always said so let's go hey hey what
do you know ma mama was right
alright did you know the Forrest Gump
expression my mama always used to say
life's baggage on that's a Swedish
expression
the Swedes invented that apparently I
have an email from a person saying hello
what I haven't seen this room before
oh dude it's mutton I haven't seen a
martini Sam's gonna take that head
alright it finishes by beating up
Martin's head sealed by Adam Hoffman
oxide
all right I kind of had a feeling it
wouldn't be a very long episode today
but don't worry bros I'll make another
video of another series so you don't
feel like oh no we only got one way out
I only got like for a minute I can't
survive must have more videos anyway
hope you enjoyed leave a like a favor if
you like this series maybe we can
convince him to make more castle sir
that was fun I wish I don't know I wish
them would make him longer I can't
really the Sun it's but I don't know 20
minutes fray through
I'm reading the guide to everyone is
making these custom stories I'd really
showed a bit Shabbat anyway that's
pretty much it
[Music]
whatever way whatever you want the
samples in the description they're only
allowed to use for the competition if I
see that someone else ain't going to be
very angry you don't wanna [ __ ] this
face [ __ ]